this doesn't look too posh does it does
it make me look fat this thing what it
makes me look fat they said that goes
okay okay clothing swap parties like
this one in F would are all the rage you
clean out your closet and bring along
whatever no longer suits you and swap it
it's a great way to spruce up a wardrobe
and it's free and it's like tis an
actress she's here to swap and brought
her daughter's along my guides as I mean
I tried to bring a lot and take a little
and in doing so empty out my closet her
daughter Clara is busy trying on clothes
and how she found anything she likes yes
a lot of things like this jacket the
scarf another jacket on the Anna sweater
in padova Netherland be a buck holds the
swap parties in her yoga studio she sees
it as a good way to reduce consumption
and waste Findus ru has sure investors
it's nice because it's also an event
people chat while they swap and it's fun
it's like shopping without spending
money swapping and sharing instead of
shopping it's an idea that's taking off
nearly a quarter of all Germans take
advantage of services like car sharing
or online swapping platforms these
computer programmers in Hamburg are
hoping to cash in on the trend Philip
lukla founded the company why own it
members uses app or homepage to borrow
whatever they need everything from a
drill to a DVD and it's free Judy Smith
hola that's why I'm yeah I got the idea
about a year ago
I thought it would be cool to see what
my friend zone what they like and need
whooping it's a way to buy less and see
my friends more often I'm v cut mine
alone to assess dezeen as a deep the
products are usually just an excuse to
get in touch with people again contact
with him ineligible but I haven't bought
anything but food this year it's also
name's minty so far the company hasn't
earned any money yet gloeckler has
financed his startup company with help
from six private investors he sees it as
a way to change consumption habits and
promote sustainability in missing any
others we don't need to buy everything
we see in advertisements for example
when a media company says we need to buy
their dvds kakatiya doesn't close all we
really want to do is watch it once and
have that experience I'm I decide if
aslam I'm IDs in Finn's alone he already
has ten thousand registered members his
dream is to achieve a critical mass so
that no one has to buy anything they
don't need to earn money he includes
advertising on his site back in a food
spirits are high the bargain hunters are
happy and they've had a great afternoon
getting together with friends but will
it really cut down on the amount of
shopping they do calvia talks about I
will continue to buy things but it's a
good mix when I go shopping i buy
exactly what I need as if I scanner
buzzes Village Calif with us and but
here there are great finds things that I
can combine and be really creative spawn
dr. Claire tp2 done my communion service
via one person's trash is another
person's treasure swapping instead of
buying it's an idea that's taken off
you